all right why is it so quiet with the
cowboys this offseason when the big news
is jerry jones going into a 7-eleven and
double-fisting bottles of cabernet
that's a quiet off-season for the dallas
cowboys
yeah mike it has been relatively quiet
you start thinking about how many shows
we've had where we've completely skipped
over the cowboys right they used to be
america's team and you know jerry's
hating this because he wants the
publicity he wants us to be talking
about
you know he's the one that's always said
hey just spell my name right everything
else follows after that i don't care
what you say so
it has been quiet i don't know that
they'll be real active in free agency i
think the next thing you hear from the
cowboys is either franchising dak
prescott or signing him to a long-term
deal and frankly i don't think they sign
until what the salary cap is and i don't
think that's going to come soon enough
for them to work out a long-term deal
they've had almost two years to do that
haven't gotten that done i do think
he'll be their quarterback this year but
i also think about that ankle injury and
how he'll come back for it and how how
quickly he can come back for it we know
we had that second surgery cd lamb
confirmed that in his comments uh on
super bowl week that that
dak prescott had a second surgery so is
he going to be able to get back and and
fully heal and be ready for the start of
the season the cowboys still think he
will we'll see about that but hopefully
he's back and he was leading the league
in passing yards when he when he left
but i think that's the next news we're
going to have is dak prescott probably
getting franchised it's just been really
quiet for them unless they get involved
somehow some way in the j.j watt thing
but i don't think they can mike not
knowing what what the franchise
what the salary cap number is going to
be and having to franchise that prescott
the reality though for the typical
franchise tag player
you don't know what the tag is until you
know what the cap is because the cap and
the franchise tag it's a percentage type
of a formula that's based on five-year
rolling average it gets complicated but
it's a percentage-driven
number
not for dak prescott because he's
entitled to a 20 bump over what he got
last year he gets more than 37 million
this year so anything they could do to
do a long-term deal is going to drop
that cap number down that gives him
extra leverage he can say here's my
proposal has todd france drop a proposal
on a four-year contract
and it gets back what he wants and look
my cap number for 2021 goes from 37
million to 19 and a half million we cut
it in half well 18 and a half million my
math sucks we cut it in half
and uh it looks pretty good for the
cowboys this year gives dak what he
wants there's a way to do it now until
some higher cap numbers down the road
but the cap will be recovered by then
but now's the time to do it now is the
maximum leverage now is the time for dak
to get the four-year deal that he's
wanted remember the cowboy said we want
five dax says i want four well he did
his one last year and he got over 31
million dollars so now let's do the
four-year deal and let's use 37.4
million as the starting point but we'll
we'll structure it in a way that it's a
it's a low cap hit this year and the
cowboys don't even need to know what the
salary cap's going to be to do that
because if they could cut that cap
number in half i think they should run
with that opportunity and as troy aikman
said dax leverage did go up and and i i
think that the cowboys would be
beyond stupid to go into the new league
year with with over 37 million tied up
in dak prescott's name and and i think
they've just finally they hit their
reckoning has arrived they've either got
to to do this deal
or they've got to not franchise tag him
i don't think tagging him is going to be
sustainable i think it's going to be a
mistake and i think he guarantees that
he's got one more year with the team and
then he's going to walk away next year
as a free agent
that's exactly right mike if they can't
work out a long-term deal and i realized
why they would do that to buy them but
if they don't get that done by july he's
not playing beyond this season for the
cowboys they'll be looking for a new
franchise quarterback and you think
about all the quarterbacks i wrote about
this that they had
looking for tony romo after troy aikman
and they looked into tony romo and but
you think about the quincy carter's and
the clint sterners and the drew henson's
and all those guys that that they tried
at quarterback after troy aikman it
didn't work out you've got to have that
guy that you can know that you can win
with they know they can win with that
prescott they've done that every single
year he played all 16 games they never
had a losing record so they can win with
him can they win a super bowl with him
that's yet to be determined but i think
they think that they can so if you do
pay him what he's worth move on have him
as your long-term starter
i want to be clear on the numbers too
last year the tag for dak prescott was
31.4
million because the cowboys chose to use
the exclusive level not the
non-exclusive the number would have been
3 4 million lower if they had gone
non-exclusive they chose the cadillac
version of the tag to keep any other
team from offering him a contract that
if he had signed it and they hadn't
matched the cowboys would have been left
with two first-round picks this year 20
bump
37.68 million and if they do it again
next year by rule
44
54.2 million next year and i remember
last year when he didn't do a long-term
deal before july 15 and that came and
went people around the league were
saying to me
i
he he uh they're not going to franchise
tag him next year well bullcrap they're
not going to franchise tag him next year
why'd they use the highest possible tag
on him this year they've already made
the decision he's the guy now maybe they
can back away from it because of the
ankle injury but shireen i think that
that given the cap they've either got to
sign him
before the deadline for using the tag or
or they've just got to not use the tag
this year because that guarantees one
more year and he's going to be gone in
2022.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports